alle meine wii sondern ganz herzlich
willkommen auf diesen conergy spielen
zum ersten mal vorbei ja gute begrüße
und dadurch spielen heute zum ersten mal
vorne beziehungsweise du spielst du erst
mal fordert ja und ich habe es dann die
katze also ich weiß dass mein bruder
spielt auch immer vor
weißt du denn um was es in fortnight
geht ja beste voraussetzungen also
erstmal das bist du ich sehr wieder
komplett chance aus ist hast du ein
echter takt was ist das neue battle.net
juni als kassandra die steuerung ist
ähnlich wie bei minecraft du hast wieder
wer es sehen mehr airbus usd genau
drücken ein bisschen billig kann
verlaufen
wer sd mit genau der fraktion die linke
hand dran dann kannst du damit laufen
sehr gut und mit der linken maustaste
kann zuschlagen und das ist alles was du
brauchst das soll auch wieder bäume
kloppen ja genau wie bei minecraft ich
finde man hat hier so einen leichten
fehler drin
wie viel das spiel gefällt mir gar nicht
jetzt geht die hunde los es ist jetzt so
dass du wenn du drückst diese hier die
katze dann kannst du dir aussuchen wohin
fliegen möchtest ich würde es satt ist
bleibt er muss jetzt leertaste drücken
genau zwischen rausgesprungen jetzt guck
mal nach links links unten links unten
ein nicht da genau dann links da wo das
blaue ist dabei dass da musst du hin
fliegt und jetzt tut mir weh dann fliegt
sie nach vorne sehr gut
weiter weiß ich eigentlich schon das als
ich habe ja ich wünsche euch wird den
echt auflegen können aber mit mein
gewicht wahrscheinlich nicht als das ist
ein regenschirm egal
ja das sind gegner genau die landen als
auch alle und das ist wie hast du den
mottowagen und keine ahnung vegas
exploit dass auf jeden fall der ort
sollte springs und da kam es einfach mal
hin fliegen genau und jetzt bist du da
genau
er tastet die bayfor überfordert das
anders jetzt geht man nach vorne in das
haus rein da siehst du schon da ist
munition die kann zu einsammeln einfach
darüber läuft genau und dass ich hier
bin ich wieder raus
warum bist du so gruselig in dem haus
also her ist hier kann wenigstens verbal
zu laufen natur ist das wichtigste
vorteil ist ja platz 75 das geht nicht
so schnell geht mir alles viel zu
schnell wie es dann bei need for speed
oder sowie die scheiße heißt oberland
eine frage sind das rad echte spieler
die spielen ja das heißt ich könnte rein
theoretisch sagt einfach den jetzt hier
im ring oder wie nicht ganz so ihr
könnte zusammen spielen aber nicht
gegeneinander das ist jetzt auf jeden
fall die nächste runde sandra und du
kannst auch wenn du willst genau einfach
raus ist sind die alpen nach hinten da
fliegen wir jetzt in den urlaub.de damit
was ist denn dein ziel eigentlich
eigentlich möchte ich die scheiße du
gewinnen deswegen muss ich ihr ziemlich
auch luca kunst im mund hat muss ja
immer nach korea ist die konzentration
er ist machen wir da fehlt doch
hinterher was denn dein problem ja die
genaue du musst den fallschirm zu machen
genauso jetzt fix sein schneller wenn du
den falschen auf fast nix leben
entsprechen langsamer aber irgendwann
wenn du halten aber im boden angekommen
öffnete automatisch den fallschirm ich
glaube nicht doch noch da und jetzt bist
du dir bei den bauern da gehörst auch
heute sehr gut nicht nur aus holz mit 26
holz das ist ja du hast du hast dich
schon so gut wie gewonnen
ja ja gut sondern alles kaputt macht
das wichtigste ist eigentlich dass
waffen findet weil du wie schon wird
wieder abgeschossen
du hast dich drei plätze gesteigert du
bist ja ich hab kein denken noch nicht
gesehen bringt mit der traktoren oder
was sie würde scheiße gegner schwierig
gefällt mir kein spiel mehr
hier sieht das spiel total harmlos aus
das hier fortnight egal das ist
solo solo bin ich auch alter wir können
gern zusammen kommen ja genau was das
denn wörter die wir haben auch ein
[Musik]
hack'n'slay ja genau
also ich will ich hier überhaupt nicht
beeinflussen bei den matten bürger warum
machst du denn jetzt schon ein
fallschirm auf jetzt abgenommen einfach
weh drücken roter fliege blabla die
sache ist ich will ich doch überhaupt
nicht beeinflussen meinte mai treffen
die mein ding machen wir dies macht man
das will jetzt will ich dich einfach
komplett ins kalte wasser schmeißen sehr
gut du bist jetzt auf jeden fall an
einem ort gelandet an dem nicht allzu
viel los ist er das ist auch schon mal
in ordnung lande mal dabei den bäumen
hinter dir zurück genau da und genau in
der mitte von dem wald diese schon da
was da so leuchtet das ist eine kiste
und kisten liegen gegenstände wie waffen
et cetera und damit kann zwar gegner
töten dabei dem trecker hatte hiller das
als aber nicht schlimm platz 95 von 99
ist nicht schlimm dachte mir den tipp
wie wär ich dir heute noch platz 136
raus also dann ist ja kein anderer da
das aber auch da ist als eher langweilig
da ja ich will trotzdem platz eins
werden
egal wie könnt ihr müsst ihr klub gehen
als er jetzt fliegen sie schon alle
ihr wollt es gibt bewegung ich bin die
geilste ich weiß ihr dass sie die
springer die sache ist dass der battle
bis jetzt in jedem moment abbricht das
heißt also alle die nicht rausgesprungen
sind werden quasi automatisch
rausgeschickt die sache ist guck mal der
links neben dir der verfolgt genau die
gleiche taktik wie du er will als
allerletztes landen
also wir fliegen jetzt schon mal ein
bisschen vor
und genau landen einfach irgendwo dabei
den bäumen weil hier ist wirklich
absolut gar nichts klar hier findest du
jetzt auch keine geilen waffen oder
irgendwie sowas aber wir sind zumindest
in ruhe gelassen
ja das ist mir alles hierzu technisch
begabte technisch begabter sehr gut holz
holz wir sind gelandet ist erst mal
wichtig weil sein
das habe ich noch gar nicht gesagt du
kannst sofort auch sachen bauen haben
eine treppe und jetzt haben wir hier
brüssel die treppe wenn noch eine treppe
bauen und das war eskaliert das
wichtigste wirklich bei dem spiel ist
dass zuerst was du hast mit dem du wenn
ein gegner kommt dass du sie abknallen
kannst uns zweitens holz oder
materialien damit du dir halt so was wie
die treppe da nichts bauen kannst die
werden jetzt alle umgebracht ich bin
einfach platz eins wir können nämlich
auch verfolgen ja klar du kann der baum
wird jetzt erstmal ein häuschen das ist
ja ein bisschen wie bisschen die
vorteile von holz doch jetzt kannst du
einfach mal diesen knopf drücken hatte
den hier und jetzt guck mal nach rechts
nach rechts das ist längst ja genau ich
jetzt noch mal linke maustaste links
genau jetzt kommt noch mal links genau
die linke maustaste und jetzt kommt noch
mal hinter dich mal linke maustaste uns
sagt der sache raus
jetzt kann ich keine angreifen ja doch
aber sie schießen dagegen das haus sehr
gut meerholz hast du nicht ich komme
jetzt wieder raus kaputt machen ich
würde sagen als erstes drückst du mal
eben kurz weil wenn du auf f klicks
genau da sf jetzt kannst du die wand
kaputt machen genau
und jetzt kann ich erstmal wieder raus
laufen das heißt sie sind zumindest
erstmal frei das ding ist bei vorteil
was die auch noch sagen muss es gibt
eine zone die wird immer kleiner so dass
sich halt die spieler irgendwann
zwangsläufig treffen müssen weil die
regel dass kommt die augen dichtung wird
kleiner
jetzt reicht's jetzt reicht jetzt kommen
die gegner sprechen den fluss zu
springen
die gehen die flussreisen da genau wie
darunter bestimmt ziemlich schnell oder
also was wäre die hast du nicht du
kannst noch so lange wie möglich wie du
willst sprinten laufen und so weiter und
so fort also alles ich muss mir jetzt
keine gedanken darüber machen
dahinten das ist atomkraftwerk das
wichtigste ist eigentlich wirklich dass
wir uns die ganze zeit in der zone
aufhalten wir nochmal oben rechts
schaust das ist die karte und siehst du
den kreis ja aber ich gehe diese das ist
gut durchs leben hat auch in der zone
und so läuft auch noch weiterhin die
zone das ist sehr gut die könnten auch
andere tag der gefangenschaft springen
sprinten springen
ich denke vor
an der stelle würden die zwei das
heutige jetzt aber endet meine lieben
freunde viele von euch haben und das
mannschaft video geschrieben dass andere
auch meine fortnight spielen soll
deswegen erstmal und ich sage euch auch
wir haben ein letztes mal das ist
genauso wie beim geschlechtsverkehr bei
dir ja gut wenn euch das video auf jeden
fall gefallen hat das gern einen daumen
hoch unter dem video her da wurde es auf
jeden fall mega freuen uns am graben da
genauso antrat auch einen kanal
neuerdings der ist in der beschreibung
verlinkter lädt sie zweimal die woche
einen block hoch geschnitten von von wem
wohl schreibt es gerne in die kommentare
was ich das nächste mal mit sandra
spielen soll oder irgendwie die auf das
wir werden mal wieder reagieren sollen
oder neue reagieren sollen oder keine
ahnung was abonniert gern meinen kanal
falls doch keinen telugu seit und jetzt
kommt wie santa cruz
[Musik]